c'est énorme tu sors jamais avec un seul
mec à la fois renvoyer tous les autres
années j'ai fait du ménage
qu'est-ce qui se passe la femme de
ménage a appelé un tuyau a pété dans ma
salle de bain ça veut dire que tu dois
rentrer chez toi on sera une autre fois
je viens voir marc vous êtes sûrement sa
femme de ménage
non je suis sa femme kate est ce que
vous venez faire un striptease pour une
sorte de caméra cachée
je t'écoute il a une femme et qui te
sens pas à la hauteur mais j'ai pensé
qu'on pourrait peut-être dîné ensemble
si vous entrez on va pas boire des
cocktails et soutien des petites nattes
d'accord je fais pas le poids face à des
femmes comme vous on s'est fait avoir
par le même mec t'es qui là où un doigt
de vodka remet alors vous dit que je
devrais quitter pour cent des quads en
poterie
pas toujours quelqu'un est pas les
doigts de tromper tout les deux parce
que c'est pas moi tout ce que vous
faites
salut je n'arrive pas à croire qu'il ait
menti
j'adore cette odeur qu'est ce que c'est
c'est ce que je sens que je transpire
alors qu'est ce que tu veux faire je
voudrais lui faire mal un coup de pied
dans les burnes
tu sais j'aime beaucoup la manière dont
fonctionne ton cerveau mais là où on
cherche quelque chose d'un peu plus
chaud j'ai trouvé ça hilarant l'axé
associé on trouve le fric et on
dépouille
réunissez l'avocate des pauvres et les
nichons et l'on saura comment y arriver
de façon aussi ce look lui
je croyais que tu lui donnes est
désormais autant qu'à trop sexuel qui va
être opéré du reggae du nil bord je
crois que tu es en plein masque y oppose
mme musculo pause ou ça vous vous foutez
de moi métral ce numéro trois si on
découvre d'autres maîtresses je pense
envoyé en cure de désintox
vous êtes les copines les plus bizarres
du monde
on est les copines les plus bizarres du
monde écoutons petit frère non tu peux
pas avoir mon mari et mon petit frère tu
jamais rassasié